[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Cloud
Shell Editor gives you
the power to easily write
code from your web browser
and deploy it to the Cloud.
In previous videos,
we learned how
to deploy applications to
Cloud Run and Google Kubernetes
Engine.
We also learned about the
Cloud code integration,
and how it provides convenient
tools to debug applications
and use Google Cloud APIs.
But what if you want to
collaborate with teammates?
Cloud Shell Editor
has you covered
with version control and
support for multiple projects.
Let's take a look
and learn more.
First, visit
ide.cloud.google.com
to launch Cloud Shell Editor.
Cloud Shell Editor
gives you the power
to manage multiple
projects as Workspaces.
A Workspace usually
represents the root folder
of your project, as well as
project-specific configuration
files.
With Workspaces, you can
specify persistent settings, run
and debug configurations
and UI states
for all the folders
in your Workspace.
Here we can see some recent
Workspaces for this user.
To open the Home
Workspace that's
created for you automatically,
click Open Home Workspace.
This opens up the
Home Workspace,
displaying all of
its folders and files
in the Explorer panel.
To create a new
Workspace, we'll first
want to create a new directory
to use as our Workspace.
Right-click on the Explorer
panel and select New Folder.
Give your new folder
a name and click OK.
Let's also go ahead and add
a new file to this folder.
Once your directory
is ready, you
can open it as a new Workspace
with File, Open, Workspace.
You can also configure settings
for your individual Workspaces.
Settings are accessible by
opening File, Settings, Open
Preferences.
Here you can adjust two
different types of settings--
User settings and
Workspace settings.
User settings apply
to all your instances
of Cloud Shell Editor, while
Workspace settings apply only
to your currently
active Workspace.
Closing a Workspace is easy.
Just select File,
Close, Workspace.
This will bring you back to the
Cloud Shell Editor homepage.
Now let's learn about how to
use source control with Git
from Cloud Shell Editor.
Click Open, Home, Workspace
to open your Home Workspace.
Now let's go ahead and clone
some sample code from GitHub.
Open the command palate by
selecting View, Find, Command.
Type "Git Clone"
and click on it.
Next, you'll be prompted to
type in the Git repository
that you want to clone.
After typing in a GitHub
URL, press Enter to continue.
Cloud Shell Editor
clones the files
for a sample application from
GitHub into a new folder,
allowing you to work across
multiple repositories
at the same time.
Right-click on
the folder created
for your new repository, and
select Open as Workspace.
You should see the list of code
files only for this repository.
Here we have a simple Python
Flask web application.
Now let's try editing the
code and pushing the change
to GitHub.
Open the main.py File and
replace "Hello World" with
"Hello Google."
Cloud Shell Editor will save
your changes automatically.
On the left side
of your screen, you
should see that the source
control icon has a blue circle
with the "1" inside it.
This means that
we have a new code
change we may want to commit.
Click on the source control icon
to open the source control Git
panel.
Now we see that we have
a code change in main.py
You can click on it to
open the [? DifView, ?]
which shows what you've changed
versus a previous commit.
Hover over the main.py file in
the source control Git panel,
and click the plus by
it to save your changes.
When you're ready to
check in your changes,
you can do so directly
within Cloud Shell Editor.
But first, you'll
need to configure Git.
Select Terminal, New Terminal,
to open a new Cloud Shell
terminal window.
From here, run the
following two commands
to set up Git from command line.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Then, back in the source
control Git panel,
write a commit message
and click the checkmark
to check in your code change.
Now you're ready to push
your change to GitHub.
Back in the Cloud Shell
terminal window, run Git push.
Type in your GitHub
username and password
to push your commit
to the master branch.
Let's head over to GitHub to
verify that our change was
actually pushed successfully.
Based on the information
about the latest commit,
it looks like we're good to go.
You can also manage source
control from the Git status bar
at the bottom of your screen.
Right now we're on
the main branch,
but we can click on it to
switch to a different branch,
or create a new branch.
There's also a Synchronize
Changes button.
Synchronizing changes
pushes local changes
to your upstream branch,
and pulls remote changes
into your local repository.
With just a couple
of clicks, we're
able to get started
with source control
and push a change to a Git repo.
If you want to experience for
yourself all that Cloud Shell
Editor has to offer, just
visit ide.cloud.google.com,
where we have interactive
tutorials to help you get
started.
From more videos on Cloud Shell
Editor and a whole lot more,
make sure to subscribe
to the channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]